we've had some time now to soak in the
rocket League Rumble update and it's
pretty apparent it's changed things up
yes there's a new rumble mode but there
are some other game changers features
like in-game party chat custom team
names and colours for private matches
custom car presets player 2 player item
trading and then the real elephant in
the room crates and keys but before we
tackle any of this crate stuff let's
have some fun and top rumble mode tips
and it's quite the mode all right in
Rumble there are 11 abilities that are
given to you at random use it and a 10
second cooldown occurs most abilities
you'll want to burn quickly in order to
pick up the more precious ones so let's
rank these tips starting off with the
more defensive power-ups and then ending
with the real power strikers the boot
kicks an opponent right out of there see
a guy running your ball downfield kick
him out of it for offense well just keep
an eye out for cars making their
approach on the ball or one venner if
you see a goalie help him get back out
on the field the disrupter is a fun one
it's a lock-on laser that cuts a car's
brakes and forces the opponent to hit
nitros like the boot you're hunting for
the opponent that's making an approach
onto the ball and if you get hit by a
disruptor you're not quite out of it you
can look for payback and take out other
players the power hitter lets you hit
the ball harder and destroy opponents
instantly if you plan to hit the ball
just make sure you're facing away from
your own goal because that ball will fly
personally I just eliminate the other
team
freezer freezes the ball crazy this one
you definitely want to hold back on
unless of course the ball is on your own
goal line but try to let others burn
their power first because it won't stay
frozen for long one better use it when
you're on approach to the ball and get
the lead on everyone else the tornado is
strictly a ruin people's lives power
you're looking to swarm opponent cars
because even though you can scoop and
somewhat guide the ball the control of
it is not that great the swapper aka
teleporter is tricky
once again you're looking to prevent the
other team from striking the ball but
feel free to leapfrog downfield and gain
some ground the grappling hook brings
you to the ball strive to use this one
offensively by always facing away from
your goal but you'll know when to apply
it defensively when the ball is creeping
around your goal the magnetizer allows
you to more or less steal and steer the
ball just make sure you're super close
because it's area of effect is weak
engage this sucker when you know you'll
have some quality ball time
now these last three power-ups in my
opinion are the pure offensive strikers
in that if you get one of these hold on
to it and find the right moment here we
have the plunger it's similar to the
magnetizer only much quicker and much
more effective this one brings the ball
to you try your best to not only be
driving downfield but with much momentum
where it's really effective is timing it
when you're just about to hit the back
of an opponent's goal it'll slingshot
the ball into the goal at some times
unstoppable speeds
the haymaker is the moneymaker once the
ball is between you and the gulp BAM
last of the lot you know what's coming
spike this goddamn ability is king it's
like giving your car hands truly Opie
but it's all about the timing wait for
everyone else to rush and then spikes
and when you're spike to it consider
getting in the air to avoid the other
team from swooping it
now that we got all the fun stuff out of
the way let's talk crates and keys when
you complete an online match in rocket
League there's a random chance you'll
get one of these crates inside the
crates
our exclusive item seen here the only
way to open it is by purchasing keys
one key cost a dollar forty nine or
twenty four twenty you then open the
crate and roll the die in getting one of
those items well let's try it out then
okay I'm hoping for this X devil mark
two variants or even these lightening
wheels well this is weird
there are however a few ways you can
avoid buying any keys one you can say
screw this and visually turn it off
entirely
meaning turn it off and you won't ever
see crates drop or the by Keys option
which is nice too you could collect five
crates of similar rarity and trade them
in for a higher rarity item three
conveniently there's now player 2 player
trading trade with your friends or take
it one further and hit the web of course
there's already a rocket League exchange
subreddit that you can look at also
worth noting you have to wait seven days
to flip crates create items or keys well
there you have it
as long as you can turn it off I guess
there's no harm here but I'm curious to
see how well this will pan out down the
road but what do you think add your
talks to their comment section I'd like
to know thanks for watching but before
we take off why don't we just open one
more crate I don't have my hopes up but
you never know